so when you got lost though because I I
wanna so were you so you obviously
audition how many times did you audition
twice twice and you tested you
auditioned twice and then the third was
a it was a test no there were so few of
us that it was one audition and a test
wow so you tested and then did they tell
you right away that you got it
there was a lot of drama around the
decision
um because I had another project that my
agent would not support me taking lost
for so that's a whole other story that
but um so they told me and uh they told
me I guess a week later and instead of
being happy I was really torn about it
because my agent had already drawn her
Line in the Sand and said you cannot do
this job and and she literally said to
me if you do this job I will no longer
be your agent so heck I actually wrote
JJ Abrams myself and I said JJ you don't
know me you just hired me but uh I I
would love to do this show but I had
this other job do you think you could
adjust your schedule for me all the
stuff an agent is supposed to do for you
I didn't do it she didn't she did not
lift a finger but I'll tell you what why
when I got lost she took every
commission check
foreign
so when I before I got mad tv no one
would sign me as an agent so I had my
manager get me
um an audition for Mad TV because she
she represents one of The Producers on
the show
and they're like he's not gonna get it
but well as a favor so he can learn the
audition anyway I get it I get to the
final right it's between me and Taryn
Killam and I remember is it really yeah
wow me and Taryn wow and he Taryn was 17
years old at the time oh my and I
remember being there sitting in their
Lobby about to go in and I remember my
somebody called me and I go he goes hey
and I go who is this he's like I'm your
agent
and I go I don't have an agent now you
do I negotiate a deal
and so they and then ever since then
they got 10 of everything so they only
came after you got the job yeah I had to
get the job before they would sign me
right well speaking of Jimmy Yang I was
watching the podcast he was talking
about his role in Silicon Valley yeah
same kind of thing right yeah yeah this
is a very common story among all of us
which is why I feel this Brotherhood and
Sisterhood with people who are like us
because we have very common experiences
and by the way yeah shout out to JJ
Abrams I never would have been on Lost
had he not changed the shooting schedule
for me I could fly back anyone else that
would do that but you killed it on that
show oh that's very nice killed it thank
you yeah but there's very there was a
very real chance I never would have done
that show but did you because I'm
curious when you're shooting the pilot
and whatnot did you in your head go this
is going to be a hit no I didn't because
it was so unlike anything I'd seen on TV
we were speaking Korean
ever and like it was truly a
multi-racial cast in a way that wasn't
just lip service you know yeah it was
real yeah yeah and and you know you're
talking about if you list if you read
the log line you could be reading
Gilligan's Island like people get
trapped on an island yeah end of story
where does it go from there you would
have no idea it's really about the
genius of those writers so so you didn't
know any of about the supernatural
elements in it it was just basically an
island crash in the first pilot and then
that's all you knew when we were
shooting the pilot there was this big
scene where we're supposed to hear this
like roar coming yeah I remember yeah
yeah and we're supposed we're at the the
plane and we're supposed to look out
there JJ literally said okay you're
going to hear something you hear you
gotta imagine you hear something super
loud out there and we're like what is it
just listen just listen for it just
listen for it it's huge it's massive
it's scary action and he played it no oh
so you have to react to a noise you're
not even gonna [__] know what it is I
think there might have been like a and
there's the noise kind of oh wow and you
go
oh wow yeah so it was a surprise to you
too as well then yeah so and none of us
knew what was happening week to week
none of us knew who who was going to die
in The Next Episode we were it was
literally a day by day wow yeah I I mean
number one that show made him right two
he is now and that that was like the
first time where I saw a TV show I was
like it's like a movie
you know I mean like the first time
where I watched a network show and I was
like no this is something like you know
I mean the first addicted show that I
ever saw where I was like I'm gonna
watch like you know me
I don't watch anything yeah but that
[__] show man was so good if that
were on today you'd be binging it from
beginning to end yeah you know and so
you know you could you could make the
point that it kind of ushered in the
binging era because remember people used
to not watch our show because they
wanted to wait for the DVD set to come
out right and then they just wanted to
watch it all together wow but toward the
end did you think it was getting a
little silly or it was it was tough it
was getting a little silly uh because
you know when the island moved that's it
that's all you have to say
yeah yeah okay when you read that the
island moves what did you I I read it
twice
what do they mean by this yeah what
about the time travel yeah so did that
weird you out no that didn't work
because you know losses on the First
shows to really use flashbacks as a
storytelling mechanism yeah yeah and
ever since then you've seen it like used
over and over again right but the idea
of like flashbacks and then flash
forwards it seemed a natural extension
of how they were telling the story and I
think even at that time there was a show
that tried to copy laws called like
flash forward or something like that on
ABC
but you know success you can measure
success by the number of people who want
to imitate it right right there were so
many lost copycats at that time oh yeah
yeah yeah
um so you know I just was along for the
ride whatever the writers wanted to do I
was game because they created this show
and I had a lot of faith in them yeah so
um even the ending people were you know
busting on the ending and stuff but I
just I knew my personal feelings were
you're never going to satisfy everybody
like we were talking about before so I
just cared about the characters I wanted
to know that the characters were in a
good place yeah and I felt like the
ending took care of that people ripped
on the Game of Thrones ending I liked it
it's hard to think about it it's so hard
to end like a multi-chapter book yeah
and you know most of the time the
writers aren't even prepared to end it
properly so you know sometimes shows
don't get endings they just get canceled
so yeah I've been on those yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's hard to please everyone
do you watch a lot of k-dramas uh
I don't know what a lot means but I
watch my share my fair share you know I
think
um Korean dramas have been doing some
things like really in a very different
way from American dramas for a long time